i'm french campo y est i'm so
google based in san francisco and i want to
talk today about cube and rake
so what we're going to do is the toque it's
going to be a bit of an intro than towards the
tice with l  idea to have a bit of an idea
of how it works from
ew revenue at an architectural level but a
so at a user level and then a hig
rhin jean baptiste david on the 2nd who w
ll tell us about how they use c
vée a métis equal to the conta
ners engine  to use it to
have all their evidence on its so
let's talk about 10.1 savior how we do that
rather than talking about how we do that
how did that there a
full year ago I think I was I had
maybe don't brag like that one of my
cousins gave me a game of milit
nt ninja turtles i'm a former frenc
man that's how it was and so it was in valen
ia so south of barcelona getti
g ready to say to  about three hours
by car
the game has melted
so here I know dice  but so
it was hard to deploy software
it's always hard
a little later nineteen years
older but what did you have
to do if you had to send
several cupic bas you had to do
several  copies are physical copies
that we send by post
so that's good but it's not
perfect so
after that we had phones and ca
n't really have a bell internet phone
and all of a sudden  suddenly in fact we changed the
way of executing the knowledge rather
than having the knowledge that the sending in fact
except savior knows we access it from
machine so all of a sudden we have the idea
of servers and clients and  all of a
sudden its customers the servers are
different and we have to be able
to have more servers all of a sudden
because the more customers and it's
not only we have more machines
this disk c  is really necessary to have
foreseen a little how many users we
will see which is a little hard so
after it  there is this side of the fact that we are going to
execute something on our side
so from another laptop
we are going to have our program we are developing
for the cries it works we are happy
and it is a bit like snow in a
swimming pool in to  inside and then all
of a sudden we launch ourselves into the sea or
the ocean even at c.difficult that we are going to
have a program which has been written for
just a sketch to run on a
machine and we want it  run on
several or more matches more in the
middle thousands of machines it's going to
be complicated so how we do it good
google is a good example of how to
do scalability level there are
several servers
we have several indeed so 1 1
many many  but what's
interesting is we pretty much have so
an excuse everything in the counter
absolutely everything moreover if you
use free canteen
jean lévy m it will be fixed which was also
container time so if you
run in containers in a  life m6
a vienna container  in a container
of an ibm
somewhere they run about
two million containers 2 billion
if I'm not mistaken it's 2 billion
because French it's difficult
every week so we did that for a
very long time and that  we've been making containers for more than ten
years, it's not
heart water containers, but
we're containers all the same, so
how did we write a paper on that,
that's borg paper
, which is what  is super nice because if
you read it you can really understand
how it works I really want I
recommend you watch it
so I'm part of a podcast is
called google apps the form of
podcasts and we interviewed john wilkes
c  he is one of the people who wrote
the paper it was super interesting
so now what we are going to do is
we are going to read the paper all together no
it would be nice anyway
but no we are not going to do that to
instead I'm going to show a bit what it
looks like at  google
as I said we have several machines
we have lots of servers and in fact we have
lots of servers on lots of dirty ones that
looks like that that's hang them at 5am
it's just part of one of the
belt  often we have several
buildings like that in the same the
same obligations
and that's just interesting heart and
one to many all over the world
so if we want to run a program where
what we accept what we say here I
would like that  cqt a good program on
this machine where do we say I
will run the program somewhere
in europe well
in fact if we wanted to run on
a concrete machine the
problem is what is happening and what machines
disappears well it doesn't work anymore so in
fact what we do is borg
we call a lausanne os system at the
system brief good the center delay when
we use a hard disk we do
n't decide exactly in the disk where we are going to
storella the  information well still nestor
something in the  e delay of the a51 we
do not decide on which machine to the
vast would have either we will be
somewhere the same way it does
not execute something we decide not sure that it cpu
if we could say it was on our
computer we say just do the
same to help the center we'll say
excuse that somewhere on one of the
machines that are incorrect to
take the lead
how do you do that it's easy to
say but not necessarily easy to do
so in fact
ona boyd a lot of things so
first floor by config
it's a worried programming language
also complete turine which
is not necessarily good but it's in
language quite cold configuration
for jobs this so we're going to say we have a  job
then we say or what we want to execute it
an insel workbook it's in fact a
part
it's a workbook it's a party
in elevators so it's fine here after
we're going to give a binary so a minor
which in binary linux
there is a noise let's say  on which port
we want we can have this service
available and then we have a list of
risk
brother requirements I want to go
beyond saying that I like
so for example how many of
the event we had tonight how many
discs
how many cpu what is interesting
is very often to have just a
part of these figures because it will
take very little but more
plan access and finally how many states do
we want to execute
so we are going to say a lexicon 8  ,5 where we
can say rather executes 10000 it's
about the same it's just it's not
us it's not developer to
manage to make it work it
's beyond the center so a form that we
unfolds and it passes in two
and a half minutes all of a sudden we have ten thousand
one sense of this black game is to hear
what is being said is in fact we never
said mid
we have about an 89  1990 a few
because we always have machines that
disappear we have jobs that no
longer work  also the award is not
necessarily the highest priority job
at google what does it mean if there is
something more important
this job disappears so that's why we
arrive and we never arrive at 10000
but in fact  that's good that's that
so how we do that in fact so that
's borg's architecture and in fact
we're going to start in ten years there's a
binary so it's our forums a real one we're
going to send it
here it's our pastor grid it's
just monster database name 1au
binary then we have this
configuration file that I'm showing you later
we're going to send it to the board masters
the master pole in fact there are several
replicas  the story that if a man
falls there is no problem
the national bank does we have skyblues
what was going on skyler they will
look
ok how many instances you have to know
if you you to take the tithe he  very
good how much a year now 0
ok it takes canadian conrad but that's
just it and it works that's it  mbert
there were some we say we have ten thousand and
now we are told that we have to
execute just 5000 well we have to
remove that it is the cska executor of theirs
who takes care of that so a form of
site that  will make I love you a master edge
will ask in strips that
's actually that it's the machines that
execute the code
that's the machine that takes care of the
programs sc borlette will retrieve the
binary it will start to  accept
it that's what door does everything we
do so all of a sudden we have a hello
world it's a bit everywhere where exactly
we don't know in fact it's good so
here there are ten thousand  copies of hello
world so the title of the toc wasn't
borg thought it was beneficial so
what's the ratio of vouchers to cuba ni this
is it it's pretty much the same thing
it's not the same thing  for several
reasons to one these boats it's
incredibly complicated and it's
really related to the
google infrastructure while berné weaves its
oppressors and has  done so
cash this is possible to use
for anyone you don't need
to have google infrastructure i have
seen that well spices run on a
raspberry pi workbook you can do
that if  we don't necessarily want i'm not going to
run your prod on
teri country rats but if you want you
can do it so that hubert
mathis does what we do we remember
like tencent games which is a
very nice way of saying  it's an orchestra
of containers that's all so we're
going to switch to a daemon very quickly so called
scott de machines on two of the
mauritians claudel
ok
ok short so what we're going to do is we're
going to create a binder and  this is a
binder that fooled this we want a little
pretty well made a binder of the container
in jeans but it takes a few minutes
are so what I want to do is to
start that what executed that and
then I will explain this  that it is
therefore as a binder said that
fooled this several years ago  urs are several
machines which executes the
code this is called on bug ball is
n is what is it tube let's it is
similar
so we can choose where we want to have its
so i will say uruguay this version
of two  cuvées in addition to executing
that you of machines we want and how many
machines we want to have so all that
is good
so I started executing and going
now however it's sexy that we're
going to try to understand what's going on
so please go by the light
tinqueux ok so we saw earlier
starts to walk to govern for
borg
let's see how it works to govern
this that's that towards the tice it's
similar anyway it's exactly the
same thing actually
before the binary well now it's
more a binary so it's a match
and actually it's no longer our limit
continued mitchum we can use
tankers much more useful and used
rockets were able to use at  point
continues so we will send make sure to
cra  bes or any history response
so for example we have a taste for the
container is from and it's
something internal private we will
also send a file to ya mail because there's
mail is not necessarily I hope on
a '  complete which is good so it's
simpler we're going to send it to the masters
now it's not nice the masters
it's just that ricemaster kobena
ricemaster basin of theirs who will say ok
good asked me to have ten  a thousand
replicas of this job there and I have none
down we have to send to convince and
news
we will ask for a dq chard
can you execute his city please the
cube the help will recover the container of
duration not locate  and begins
to accept it that's all it's exactly
the same thing we had earlier
but that's all to the benefit also
another difference if you've never
seen me I do gore all the time  time so
find an artist write yang ho and
bring it's written in c++ ccc ccc some
interesting code it's  complicated
so it's these bearded years ok so that
's from
an architectural point of view from a user point of view
what are the concepts
you need to know to use
the first c like a matisse  is the concept of the pod is
a fact it's very simple it's a buddy
it's just several containers that
are together
why well in fact it's because
each container each buddy sorry
what fool weaves a private network
so we can use for each
container each each pod until when
you come to say when was born instead
of friends each code little by little say
I use port 80 and in fact they will
have their ip and their port 80 does not prevent
how many friends we run are for
example siona 10000 pod which folds from
port 80 on three savak machines worked
well which makes these
pesson seizures are virtual and his park manager
bernetti stonger has nothing to manage
if we want to have two
different containers in  the same network is there
that we use pods
for example a typical example is for the
dwarfs the content of a
in observe the content for a cms and
then the code for the cms are not
necessarily the same thing we
may have them at the same time  but it has to
be in such a way that they are a set
of forms in order to work so this is an
example after with controller and completely
contravenes there are lots of different types
there is a replica controllers there is also what
is called deployment  the idea here
is to say ok how many pods
we can have for example we're going to say a
break the controls are fast and with
acerbic replies who says I'm going to have
ten thousand bodies of emile friends that's the
one who's going  to say ok is what we said
even they didn't have to anchor more
so these rooms where we will create all
the constraints of how many
times those who support you have to but also
where would they do  to execute it we
will for example be able to say I
want to execute it on nodes which have u  don't
label a specific label including for
example because they insisted on
trying to be like that it's precisely
here as we decide seconds it's
finally seen that the
pods have zips and we don't control
how we do it  to access it with
services and the services it's
simply an access point with several
modes it's a little more complex than that
but it's a fairly simple way to
understand so we're going to see some friends who
are replicated  by a controller and which
are accessible by in service so
why that towards the tice what do
we with the magnetism which has that
with other things such as for example
embarrassment after with jean baptiste we go
so we just used system  d
already what is the line so it is not up
to us to manage ours executes what we
are told he could force worship and this
job there on a machine that works
no problem or it is exactly we
are also able to manage life sakho
is new
which is interesting  it's that we
install a job it's not because the
job is working that it's ready to receive
traffic this worst we were on a
health concept from the readynas finesse buddy which
allows us to know when a server
should be  stay arte where we
still don't have to send traffic because we
're still not ready
rihanna if skying we can't create
against controllers that
allow us to do well in fact I don't know
how many replicas we want so
we have to have as many  replicas that are
needed to manage the traffic
that also this something that manages one
like hermit his name in game disc overy
it's once we created a service we
give a man to this service and that
would be accessible directly by speaking  there
and girl discovered nittis but
also as a dns so for example we
created the world service online in the dns
accessible separately from any
post
which makes it very easy
to call the service  slow no matter where
he is  to run
there is also the other balancing so if we
start sent traffic plan
will not stop that often will not be
distributed across all the people
discusses which mainly affects the nodes and
then also you come out volume that's
right  docker pretty much so i know by
something awesome logging
monitoring if it's directly attached
to tail at cuba parking lot analysts szostak
it's something that's fairly
new but on go capa funds
specifically on the continent jeans
in  fact it's very attached instagram
we were talking a little later to moreover
been wagered china this for google apps the
end all the part is what in fact
also rare bac so rubeis taxi stops
having it's at the end worth base  access
control robin sax like that so we
can say who has who has access to what so
towards the tice there are plenty of things
we can do there is no looting
so who can do what
and finally we call it piranha take
advantage  ch  a month ago that I prefer the
pdc with proof of rigor since in fact
we had problems on google the
platform what an American who
ate cables so it happens
and the idea is that even if they had
a  shark who ate in help with
some letters the infrastructure
keep going
ok so we're going to have a dirty one is
crow thomas and machines
ok so our class tors is ready
what we're going to do is we're going to click
here
copy that that  going to be said cloud
it's the only part we're going to do that
is directly linked a little dirty in
fact that we're going to do it's just on
schedule there like the credits than one
thing the access data  to the workbooks
because otherwise we everyone to
access it if we can access the spikelets
it means that we can create
new workbooks we can also
remove them which is not something
very easy very very well to allow to
do  everyone so we're gonna do that
ok so now i'm using  eclipse
city occupies carrot cake launched the whole
like use to control kevin
harris
it's just a trick actually it uses
behind the pia and so we could
all we can do checkups we
can do it directly on a and pia
let's use rest so we can make an
example show me all the knots
we said we wanted to have three hours
the three are not the actions in the process
of being executed who can boast mate there
are no mates it's normal we come
so if we  just created the crafter
so it's empty
so now what I want to do
is how many of you use the
cei 1 command on mac
it allows me to say things it's
funny I teach children
used with it  computers
once all the apprentices the thresholds
know there are no more classes it's over
so what we're going to do is stop
accessible only for mac
so what I want to do is I make
a threshold that  is server client I had
a server that will be  re c is a client
that will access the server that
runs on analysis cube
using high school I enjoyed
course but we won't talk about it
today so there's code go it's
not super interesting but it's  is open
source its specific case you want to
watch this just on guy gold cloth
like that whatever it does so
you'll pay to keep it I'll put a
link later but what's interesting
is that we make it good guy in  so we
're just going to create a docker container so
to host match has been created now
what I have to do is I have to
send
these containers south 1 on ingres is from and
the story some twenty artists
can access it rather than
put it directly on doc rab what if
we put crab shoes in public
it's actually it's opensourcing and
I can't just do that in
front of everyone what I  I'm going to
do it's the push and on 10 yards from
Laguiole gisti has moreover it's
gouga  ud container is fresh and actually
it's but doesn't stop and it's the
name of the project I created for
today so it's something that's
only accessible to people who
have  access to this project there so it's only
me so I gave birth before because
I can't necessarily find the wifi so
now what I'm going to do is I
'm going may hamm offered so my opinion
we said there are friends there are  reply to
dia controller is a service
the first one said to himself a
diploma knows a bit between the two it's a
bit between the description of friends but
also the description of a controller
so we have a name these diplomas we
recalled how many jobs one can run this
program in this case I
was just asking to have three and a
bath wants to see you ja but the daïra who
has the left eye and that's important
because that's the  how
cries we say a little all the containers
all the friends and with the services
it is with lives so in
saying this is the name ceap cei
this is our beautiful ones and after what
we do we to the
container description the code description to
all the containers there was just a
try just my image from google will
continue  sweat with port 80 80 i was
moving a little story i should have
done this before maybe like this you
get to read it ok so now
what i'm going to do is i'm going very its
cutie third creed hf
here it is c  it's done so what did I
do here I've made friends now
there are three friends that's all how
I manage to access it's beyond
well in fact I can't because I have
not create a service for the moment so
now will create the service so the
service what we have is so we say that
it is a service we also give a name
but the important part and its
readers we will  say we're going to send
messages to friends who have
ap apps it's that my ltte opinion the time that
's how we make the connection and  in
vain exposed the port 80 80 cp outputs
as the other swing and that's
interesting because what means
is when I'm going to create my service
we're going to have the service of the collective
it's a fact it  supported that we can
only access from the inside had to place
but now we have also created an
excellent the api have great standing
in fact what is doing here
is in-house it is very fast has
created it  is neither done because its
virtual an excellent it a little more
complicated we are in fact creating
on the other swing on gauclin
sometimes so that is completely
integrated and if we are lucky his
approach and in a few seconds
and they make a little of that we're going to have
a hip hip directly and externally that
you could use if you want the
only problem is that of the pharmacies
so it's going to be complicated ok so
now we have that so I'm going to copy
his life  was going to my client for
bild so i did the backend it's going to
be  re that and I mean then that swells
to that but you had task you sweat shirt
hp dachau
what am I doing ah yeah I'm
doing something weird
wow
why wouldn't that work a name
because his life so I see  that it's the
bar gül who what
no but still waiting it's no
it's a name ok age pee so ok
so we sent this is what was
happening we created a message sent on
bin n you can see it
worked because it created a new
file that was modified just
now so it's not it's not
it's real there and now it's
all good i can run  this
robots file him why the iphone
here it is not beautiful but it works very
well so like that now we can
see only our friends and our services
and if we go here we are also able to
see my machine only on the network hockey
died again second
time today
ok we will pass east of cotonou
lykke friis whatever you want  have to show it's a
fact there is you can see all the
machines and also their hour scales
since the old ones but hey it's not
a big deal so what we saw is there
are two parts there is the part there  ya the
cuban part haiti which is in fact
completely dependent on the swell
run these little cubans it's the
same everywhere
so if we run on our machines or
on cloud aux something somewhere
in the middle it's going to be exactly in a
club too  something that allows us
to do is in fact it will allow
to create contacts which are very
clear between the developers and those
who manage the production so it is against these
contracts in fact it is the diamond point file
but  which allows us to very
easily have developers who want
to deploy directly on
the prod
but also something between
the authoring system which between the
decline between the decline because it is
among other things because it is q
something that we are going to have on several
machines is passionate about my machine
learning system center and the black so
I only use a container jeans in
fact the software the part as
it is called is it not the software well the
maquis but give up saint catalan
hardware I like the word so it's
the hardware in fact it's going to be
additionally managed by
someone else somewhere so what's good is
developers and hardware its complement
of  an independent complement now
which is really nice so who
use govern tice in the world
really not the world there is me what
i like is pokemon go it's a
very interesting story to start
walking but there is also  people for
example original dj
that's because he doesn't leave on google
apps iphone because we are
necessarily competitors but we still work
together on cooperation ok
so we said to the glaucoma part does
he feel it  is the fact that we don't have  to
manage the equipment which is very nice
because that means that we will have google
which manages all the equipment if a
machine falls it's not up to you to
manage that
it's a google so it's called
biggest accounts in the region and it's
precisely phone i managed trivializes and
that's interesting because that's what
it means is that we'll be
able to use production and manage
everything  you want but on the other hand
there is not to manage if a machine which
falls or imagine that
it is necessary to approach that it is not with you to do that
it is to save belgium jining and it is
with us  so what that brings back is in
fact we have backups monitoring
starring a broken sizing place so for
example that fooled weaving cap to create
more friends automatically
but on the other hand it is not able to
create more  machine google containers
angie is able to add
machines that leicester city info if
the info bourget manage the work for them
too  we have to remember this
figure ours sls and 99 points 100%
which is rather high but apparently
there are people who do more than that we
'll see that later there's a very good
integration with that fooled tice and  the
rest of the left their boss so we're
going to have the whole login
monitoring part and all that which is going to be
completely managed with what's very
very easy to manage because there's
nothing to do it's automatic
and if a lennon  so what's called the
cub let's thigh the machines that
run the homies they're gonna be
scaled up automatically which
means if there's a new version of
gubernatis you don't have to do anything it
's sometime it's not gonna be  migrated
to the new version of cuba in eti
are stingy with lace for your poor
jobs
so it's not up to you to manage that and if
for one reason or another
yann des nodes which breaks down and
stops working has you  nothing to do
we will remain a cream again for
you so who use google counted
jeans done there are plenty there are also
wear mango s were they are here there
is a lot of traffic here so it was
good it was very interesting and we
learned a lot
let's do that but there is also
many others but in fact diana there is
one of the companies that use gmail
at is here today to speak with
us so with that i'm going to
welcome jean baptiste david to the head
of infrastructure hello i have a bed
so first of all thank you for joining us
we are going to talk about elise is apart from the
logo which is super cool what do
you do then to the enemies it's very
simple it's an application for those
who don't know who  allows you to
geolocate your friends so very quickly and
therefore who will allow you to be joined
and all that in real time so always
for us it is the most
important point it is always real time
so by offering you the context which is
the  therefore context of a map and
emo  tifs there are a lot of people it's
very important
ah ok so who is still head
of infrastructure at a bed in by
the infrastructure as tell me
the story then the story of two friends
it's quite interesting in fact
because it  it's a story that started
more than two years ago now so
it's a story that started on
red bull or is it so at the time we
didn't use to occupy haiti of which we
were sure system d so more  of heart
so you can imagine that it's a
little bit complicated it's interesting
tonight choice questionable but interesting
it allowed us to advance from advanced
enemies to make the company grow but
it was actually not really
practical
so we  started a migration on 10 6
pi now a year and a half dakar ago and
the whole migration actually
lasted three weeks three weeks three
weeks only from the time you
started testing a little checking
started changing stuff until
m  How do you have the prod on their
exhilarating scent so knowing that it's
the hostess who took the most time for us
and you did tests
it's me I would hate it's
nice a so I imagine  that it's
because you were already on gawker that
passing water because containing one place
or another it was not so difficult
annoyed more infrastructure
indeed as we were 2.1 on
docker for us it  was very simple to
migrate finally
on cuba n 6 did not have to change anything there
was just the set up of our
infrastructure sure that bers business
so it was quite relatively simple
so you migrated what 26.1 or
cutlery laetitia large containers angie
or cockpit so we will use count
our origins okay on jessy pi so
today in france too we look
like what it's not a nail only comes out
around 10 and 12
so it's about 200  unique pod that
runs on our infrastructure therefore
unique therefore different and by  on the other hand,
it's more than 2,000 workstations that run
every day in production, so that
represents around 3,000 containers, we have
more or less at home what you have
several containers with friends,
so it happens to us, it rarely happens to us,
in fact, we agree  what we
want to do as much as possible is to
fill as many machines as possible to
use as well as possible so in this case we
only group together and we use the pod
only when we want to
share the same look back so there even the
same local network for our accounts and
so I had you 200 different posts
which means sandor imerys has so
you deploy 200 images every day
so when we happen on average we
are about 30 deployments per day
in  knowing that in fact with us the
developers deploy every day so
we are interesting we are only
two managed from the ops at the enemy dakar
but on the other hand our developers
are deploying every day and in
average these 30 but it can go up to 100
much more so there are two people
who manage all the production the second
person is there she is right in front of
him that's him so that's rather nice
these two to have than two people
who  manage the production with two workbooks
and 2000 friends running at the same
time if we had to do that with a
system said I think it would
still be a little more complicated it was very
interesting in any case
ok so we talked  a bit of 10 km
is what I would like to talk about now
that's what you have so you have 99
points 14 which is very good
we are at 99 points 50
but on the other hand you have 5 9 yeah and well
we are  went between the drops,
that is to say that we did not have a
problem the only problems we had
today on gk us was completely
our fault and over a year
it has been almost and has almost this
figure  -there that's true impressive
1 c I suppose and you have and it happens
to have  r deployments who who does
n't see who doesn't always always all the
baht measures I hope beats often we have
deployments that spit months vm
thierry start they did everything to me there all
the time
susan lee was done so that  everyone
can crash all day long and
we never lose the application
finally interesting in someone a
deployment it goes very well
as do you have a back role
of the systems it is automatic
the roll back which we use  only
the so deployments on cube is
a v6 so the bac role is completely
automatic
yes finally so we really
have who don't have much to manage and
once again it's the developers who
do unac deployment this deployment
does it's  it's up to them to roll back none in
case of failure and that's if the bones we were
talking about earlier the health part
we can see if for example start
making plans and the new pod
doesn't arrive  we can never know
that in fact that we should not continue
to make member plans stop it
and restart that it's really nice
ah ok so twelve classes later you will be
why in fact we once again
have design and where saint denis to be able to
fail by group
so in the end we are doing future
resolution including at the level of our
clusters so that is to say that we are going to
have features that go to
application features we have athens generic
data signs security all these  things
there that are isolated from each other
so if we allow several things
that allow us to manage the cracks
of each of these clusters but also
to isolate teams,
that is to say that today we can
manage access directly  to our
teams to their clusters and what
concerns them nor when in agreement in his
twelve turn 1 classes on google when
irene jean bouhey completely
independent completely how
do you manage to understand what is going on
we only have one  only solution is
monitoring which is extremely integrated
and I see it is so integrated that
it is in a binder its 1 kloster years
in its own right what is in it then
in this cluster what is it at eni we
use prometheus so
promising what is it if you don't know
it is a system that was made at
soundcloud which is therefore a
recent monitoring stand but which is
extremely extremely powerful which
was inspired by claude clair's design
so be careful that the father  it's not the
same scale as us what we decided
to do is to put two instances
of prometheus that do exactly the
same thing at one time you are so that is
to say that the two we are supposed to
find  almost the same data
on these two prometheus
it allows us to do what it
allows us to be sure to be always up at
the monitoring level
we can lose an instance without ever
having a problem and in addition it allows us
with promising you to  you have to make
requests that are quite heavy that
requires a lot of cpu that requires a
lot of time it allows us to
balance it very well and what is
interesting is why prometheus
prometheus was also part of
the year of the copiers links foundation
r  if it's written in gore like all the
good care why does it work
well together not
we have a big advantage over prometheus we
have a perfect and almost
perfect and completely automatic integration
with prometheus with whom half six per year
it's  to say that a simple annotations
on a service that bernie 6 allows you
to monitor completely automatically
everything that I will be able to
put behind so that makes 2 data
machines of the application data or m
wonder what you want it is
completely automatic and all of this
was based on the lakers who
used to deploy the
services before very well a ok so
you use go when angie e  do
you use other things
other than google is not hungry so yes
today we have other needs
we have performance needs which
are extremely important so in
particular on everything they want this
system  curling and database for these
things we need to have vms that
will have extremely fine tuning
to have the best
possible performance and in this case we
simply use gsee in fact candid
tuning what is it today  his
jean carnel dressings or the optimization
according to the parts that we will use in
particular on our databases we will
constantly try locals which
are moreover faster than given you
dared
ok so now we have a
homogeneous group  with lots of friends who
run
alain side and there they need
to access kafka how how do we do
that
how does it actually work we use the
flexibility that 26-26 allows you to be
extremely flexible when you create
your ser  vices you the data of its
readers so that they fall on the correct
mode wii is in fact the service behind
they use what is called paint
if you define yourself your
endpoint with these services you
actually offer inside  from cube bern
use a completely
transparent way to access your bm6 endpoint
are the ip from where vm inside the
cluster it's completely transparent
you talk to the services they
say ok so for the mates  which
are of a taste when angie if kafka
apologizes outside or inside the
workbook it's like in the same
new code
it's the same for us it's
completely the game very interesting
also you use  if the db is what
then if the baby for those who
do not know it is a fork of
cassandra therefore which is not in java
but only c++ and which offers
performances which are often
completely incredible it is  not written
a glove ok let's talk about stack driver is
what  you don't use it what you
used first tube and for
mestack monitoring mission through done
monitoring in google apps iphone we
don't use flavor monitoring
okay because promising for us
is much more interesting more
powerful heavier  deployed but but
but different on the other hand this river tag
offers incredible possibilities in
particular of the login that today on
this live and we you can follow the logs
of your friends live with really just
a click of buttons you can
filter them  and so that my use it
every day and a lot and we
also recently use the trail sing
star driver which has almost just been
released and which is an extremely
powerful tool if you want to start
optimizing your applications and especially to
debug in fact  so side when ging is
what to do something
special for pride on star carver
then we are lucky we are
unique shape uniquem  all of the Hamburg applications
that's good that's that that's good
so for us it's that together
to integrate it we only use
open trekking drivers okay and then
we communicate directly with it with its
rigor  to communicate our s ok so
we modify the code a little to have the
racing work and win what with
in your wins what we win we win that
today for example we want to
know what is the speed of
noqui  on our on our database
sorry and well the tracing will allow you
to do that so there you manage to see
on all the traffic over an hour
on all the trails that have been created the
distribution in terms of speed between
all traffic
so  there we can see that we are on
a p 99 which is below a millisecond
very well that's that it's really
very cool it's quite fast all the same
month
so ok so we talked promised
thiesson spoke so we  fate to give his
first son for the east for  the rules
the routes after monster stuff on
this pleasant for real après skis
and other places where you will be
stuff to see them afterwards so yes
we are a social network
so we have our mines anonymize all our
data and we  twists everything in big wave
bomb bikkuri to allow us to
do business analytics
which is extremely important for
us and why big horrible because
we don't have the manager finally
managing today a big
data system is  long it's hard we don't
want to do and we use bicois and
for that we have a big advantage with be
queen is that everyone at
enemy can perform a crisis urbik
wayne it's sql
so n  anyone with some
knowledge of what they can achieve
a time everyone can
access all the data to everyone
but is globally that sense okay
so what you do is you
analyze yourself give everything and  send you on
a big th  ree after it will be a
direct access and I find that it is a
little similar
the fact that these crowds imanatche so the
fact that there are plenty of machines behind
say you will have your rock and all that you
have not manage this roughly  the same
thing the same thing on poverty is
nothing it's always the idea in fact it's
all that will be too complicated or
too complex to manage if we as a service
manager who has been using it for a long time
and suddenly you only have
two people to do the production rate
and suddenly there are only two of us very well
thank you very much
[Applause]